oh my goodness  my knife has never had an easier time  going through me cheers  [Music]  wow  yeah holy moly this is how people live  [Music]  my name is andreas roller i'm the  executive chef here at nikken staff  steakhouse in downtown l.a here we have  our beautiful 28 day dry aged prime  phone in ribeye we dry it here uh on  premises so why why do you dry it maybe  not the right term but it's a little bit  like spoiling on a very controlled level  to tenderize the meat here you see i put  a lot of salt and you know a lot of  people when they first see this they're  like oh my god this is a lot of salt but  believe me at 28 ounces you want to make  sure your steak is well seasoned so  we're putting our steaks on what we're  looking for here is to get that  caramelized crust on the outside the  characteristic of the flavor i always  use this probably it's like it has a bit  nuttiness you know when you have a  cheese that is matured